[Musique]
danses et chants poussée des ananas
ils pourront parcourir jusqu'à 15000
kilomètres pour se rendre dans nos
épiceries comme ici à rimouski
le matin quand on arrive on fait les
annales à décortiquer cette clientèle
aime bien avoir déjà tout près et tout
cuit dans la brochure peut dire comme ça
après tout ce trajet souvent certaines
parties du fruit sont tout simplement
jeté des fois il les semaines les
injections gigantesque affecter les
pertes sont d'immenses sur sa collecte
il faut qu'ils s'assurent que le
consommateur va avoir un bel en
attendant son pot vous faites pour cela
ils s'assurent que la n'interdit gros
pour qu'elle la paire pour satisfaire en
bout de ligne le client qui veut on n'a
pas refait le laisser seul enjeu
jérôme a eu l'idée de sauver ces retail
d'ananas
car cette temporisation génère des
tonnes de déchets du gaspillage
alimentaire et plus encore selon
l'organisation des nations unies 17 % de
la nourriture disponible pour les
consommateurs et jetez la limagne
d'abord été produit que de l'eau qui
était mis dans le processus et de la
main d'oeuvre cantine un processus du
conditionnement qui étaient utilisés
pour garder frais cet aliment là et du
transport jusqu'à nous dans l'entrepôt à
l'épicerie et le thé finalement est
encore plein de belles baril savoureuse
plan de warrants nutritive qu'on veut
jeter parce qu'on est trop de travail à
elle valorisée à les récupérer ou t on
sait pas quoi faire avec mais il ya
quelque chose à faire avec
il a donc fondé ellipses conservation et
jérôme on est venu nous présenter son
projet c'est un beau projet d'économie
circulaire je vous avais besoin de
denrées pour pouvoir faire la production
la lyophilisation de ses produits puis
d'un autre côté mais avait besoin
d'endroits pour pouvoir faire c'était ce
vendre le produit aussi donc c'est une
belle collaboration
c'est une petite magie que jérôme à
montrer parce que j'ai une surprise de
voir qu'il peut faire quelque chose avec
ça je vais utiliser mes compétences
d'ingénieur pour rendre accessibles à
l'utilisation en puisant des denrées
calade ajouté
chaque semaine ils parcourent la ville
pour récupérer dans trois épiceries des
retail d'ananas d'autres fruits rejetée
ainsi que du yogourt il transforme le
tout en collation grâce à la
lyophilisation
l'accusation s'est intégré
déshydratation qui utilisent le froid et
le vide plutôt que la chaleur pour
enlever l'eau des aliments en train
d'enlever plus d'autres la
déshydratation tout en conservant tous
les nutriments que presque pacha la
réplique d'un processus
c'est dans son atelier que tout est
transformé david le nouvel employé
récupère la pub en grattant tous ceux
qui restent sur les écorces d'ananas la
pulpe est réduite en purée et congelés
puis prête pour la lie aux phillies à
sion tout comme ses choeurs d'ananas
tranchée
de l'utilisation
de
la machine
le cycle de lyophilisation dure en
moyenne 40 heures jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y
ait plus aucune goutte d'eau dans le
produit on obtient aliments légers sec
qui conserve ses valeurs nutritives à la
presse c'est le pur est dans la norme et
la purée de fraises etc et ici on a
quelque chose qui vers ma fondation
va rimer est incroyable c'est toujours
des textes qu'elle ne jamais manger
parce qu'ils payent pas grand chose
qu'on a mangé dans la nuit qui on y lit
office
ben moi je suis sa mère je suis là pour
aider et saviez-vous qu'en gaspiller
autant d'ananas noms incroyables on fait
juste deux épiceries puis on est à
rimouski là je dire on n'est pas dans un
incroyable moment c'est quand même elle
qui m'a inculqué ces valeurs le cac on
était plus jeunes et de faire du
recyclage de manger ce que les skis
qu'est-ce que dans le frigo fait que
c'est vraiment le fun l'éventail de nous
aider en cuisine et mario bros
d'accompagnement et courrez vous la leo
fille lisa sion vous connaissiez cela
aucune idée des coûts et à 20 de vue le
sortant pluzz ici on offre un mélange de
bandes en la battant l'as haguenau marre
un petit peu mais quand on lamballe on
la mélange souvent avec do you go avec
la texture du vieux beaupuy avalant
l'ensemble c'est vraiment super bons
docteurs envoyés pour l'acheteur je te
suis résoudre les jeunes sont vraiment
laden de gaspillage nous sommes motivés
en va plus
et que si on a le car de l'ana ce qu'on
avait dit le trancher pour les lieux
visés est clairement vraiment simple
mais ça donne quelque chose de super
croquant le jeu peut aussi y
plantant demain ça goûte beaucoup le
sait ce qui c'est impressionnant j'avais
vraiment l'impression que mangent les
coûts
mais c'est énorme chip mais c'est sans
friture
[Rires]
aujourd'hui giron me fait un test avec
des asperges alors on l'espère son frère
tu arrêter la machine
elles ressortent légère comme une pie
croquante et pleine de saveurs fait quoi
et bon vent lego a définitivement
falloir trouver des partenaires qui
perdent ils aspergent c'est vraiment
trop beau
mais les pertes dans un département de
fruits et légumes pour mon tour de 3%
chiffre d'affaires je département c'est
quand même beaucoup mais avec les bacs
lundi matin aujourd'hui les besoins sont
tellement un grand hall min min b
inévitablement il y en a toujours un peu
a ajouté malheureusement il en reste
encore beaucoup il reste beaucoup il
reste même pour une tranche tout de même
son voeu silo dépendant de l'accrocheur
d'ananas aussi
c'est même pas des pertes monétaires
pour les épiceries parce que si c'est
une erreur et c'est quelque chose qui
est jetée du convoi quoi tout le monde
ils sont surpris en est vraiment de quoi
faire avec les retards et de budo nana
mais c'est 30 % quand même de la matière
qu'on récupère qui valorise et exploit
gigantesque mais les quantités sont
gigantesques péter 30% d'une immense
quantité c'est beaucoup de temps
avec ce qui se passe le type ils savent
surtout aux yeux
il est capable de faire quelque chose
avec saut mais je pense quand même
quelque chose à faire dans toutes les
régions du québec est dans des modèles
plus seulement comme le note dans les
épiceries pour enfin vraiment dressons
questionnaires alimentaires à grande
échelle par des petits projets à petite
échelle à échelle humaine
[Musique]